you grew up with your great-grandmother
in the house yeah my Gregor my Carrie oh
so okay now it was she she must have
been quite elderly when she was living
with you it was 106 years old yeah yeah
hundred is six was she what kind of
personality was she what was she like
I'm she was all crazy she was a little
nasty she was sent in this love waste
eat right by the hallway where people
had to walk past and she were always
like going to get dress or fondling you
but like anybody who walked past it
doesn't matter who was she'll touch you
and people be like what your grandma
like what's up with her I think that's
my great-great granny but yes I think
she had like a freaky fetish I don't
know she was old and worn out you just
can't see hundred they grabbed her
button your crotch yeah no that doesn't
happen let's sit on sit on a lap and say
let me then you know you in trouble come
sit on my lap why do nothing I'm not
sitting on your lap but she liked the
spank people I don't it was weird it's
just so fragile so [ __ ] be like just lay
it so we didn't want to like make them
share last days look why not let's sit
on brainy lap she I mean not sit what's
she gonna die anyway but I mean I'll sit
there and and she'll like I'm sorry I
don't I'm just here listening I'm
letting all of this wash over me like
beer on a splinter you know
[Applause]
you